herr professor zastrow jetzt aus hygiene
sich aus medizinischer sicht noch einmal
die frage wie sinnvoll
denken sie ist jetzt dieser zweite
locker und angela merkel will ihn zwar
so nicht nennen aber bis auf die schule
muss man ja tatsächlich sagen ist das
eigentlich das komplett herunterfahren
unseres öffentlichen lebens und bis auf
den einzel lange das fand ich auch schon
wichtig dass wir selber noch mal darauf
hingewiesen hat also auch für mich ist
es überhaupt nicht überraschen das ist
auch absolut richtig wir wollen ja die
kontakte mindern
und eigentlich ist das die logische
konsequenz daraus dass die gewünschten
und empfohlenen maßnahmen nicht
freiwillig durchgehalten worden und da
haben wir immer gesagt und entschuldung
ich habe auch gesagt wir werden keine
zweite weltkrieg wenn wir uns an die
regeln halten und leider haben sich viel
zu viele nicht an die regeln gehalten
ich bin auch noch optimistisch dass die
kurve sehr schnell wieder abflacht aber
ist das eigentlich zu erwarten gewesen
und es ist auch nichts neues dabei also
so eine tragödie sich sagen die jetzt
sagen sie denken dass die kurve ganz
schnell wieder abflacht bedeutet dass
wir das vielleicht in einer art
teufelskreis kommen sie vielleicht ab
zur weihnachtszeit dann freuen wir uns
alle gewöhnen uns wieder daran dass es
irgendwie wieder geht und spätesten ende
februar anfang märz stehen wir wieder
hier und stehen vor dem nächsten blog
dauern und das ganze so lange bis wir
endlich ein impfstoff für alle haben das
kann durchaus passieren also ist die
frage wie lernfähig sind unsere
mitbürger wer jetzt sagt okay das haben
wir jetzt kapiert und wir müssen uns
jetzt auch an bestimmte dinge halten
dann werden wir das nicht erleben aber
wenn alle natürlich die tassen hochleben
lassen kommen dass sie maßnahmen wieder
zurückgefahren worden sind dann kann das
unter umständen wieder passieren der
impfstoff ist noch nicht da mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren